some time talking about security for a
little bit so that the first is any time
that you start to have machines
gathering lots of data I think people
are just worried about like hey where's
the data gets stored how do you make
sure it's secure how does that get
treated who does get shared with etc how
do you think about so the best practices
there and like at what level of maybe
awareness should people have given these
certain devices like you know the
Alexa's in their homes Google homes etc
listening verse not listening and all
that yeah and that's why we have to give
the Apple team a lot of credit right if
you look at how their architecting you
know how they're going to find things or
in their architecture for how they may
be you know showing if if somebody that
had that virus cross paths with you or
not right they're really looking for
ways of you know how do you have your
cake and eat it too right so how do you
have the the power of technology to help
you in in certain regards by finding
things or making sure that you're not
getting sick while at the same time
preserving your your privacy and so I
think people are being a lot more
thoughtful towards architecting a ways
of essentially putting bumpers around
what you're sharing with brands because
I think even Facebook right you know
everybody's turning the corner to say
all right and we're not going to have
this unfettered access anymore
and you know we need a lot more trust
between us and our users as well they're
the roads or users gonna go elsewhere
yeah what about the the debate around is
AI evil or not right which i think is a
funny debate in the idea of like
technology evil or not but there's
definitely people who would argue
artificial intelligences the greatest
risk to humanity and there's others who
would argue it's you know the the most
beneficial thing that could possibly
happen I guess how do you just think
through that trade-off and and do you
give any credence to the whole you know
AI is evil or or is a big threat to
humanity right so that's that's like you
know trying to project morality to a
hammer right if you put a hammer into
Bundy's hand versus Jimmy Carter
you're gonna have two different outcomes
right Jimmy
Ted Bunny's gonna harm somebody and
Jimmy Carter is gonna build you a
Habitat for Humanity so it really is III
would not be looking at a form of
Technology and automatically assuming
it's it's positive or negative I mean it
has no such spin if you will right it's
it's really what are you going to do it
with it right how are you going to apply
it in some cases it's it's going to
affect your privacy in other cases it's
going to help you hunt down vaccines so
it really depends on how you use the
tool yeah and do you think there's
things that we can do to maybe not
prevent but at least disincentivize the
negative use cases right kind of to your
point of if the technology falls in the
wrong people's hands or supplied in the
wrong way
are there things that can be done to try
to Shepherd us away from that or is it
just like other technologies where you
know bad people are going to do bad
things and good people are going to do
good things yeah I think it organically
it meets its end if you will right where
the majority of people are going to be
using it for positive means because the
community in the market was would
essentially not reward negative uses of
this technology now it doesn't happen
overnight but certainly there's there's
no reward for it in the long term yeah
and we're talking I think the
applications of artificial intelligence
machine learning voice recognition etc
in what I'll call kind of the current
state and to a short to medium term I
think one of the long-term implications
that people are paying attention to or
long-term applications is things like
neuro-link etc we're actually start to
merge the computational power with the
human body and so there's applications
that have been discussed literally
taking it putting in your brain all the
way to some people would argue you know
something like an Apple watch is
starting to get closer and closer air
pods etc how do you just think about
kind of the meeting of those two things
with such powerful technology augmenting
humans in some way yeah that's an
interesting one look we're worried about
disinformation in our news feeds
right in in Twitter and Facebook and
stuff like that so once the machines are
blended too into our minds are we
actually the ones voting for the people
that were voting for or is there some
undue influence that's being applied
towards you know you know parts of our
mind it's gonna be an interesting debate
you know to see where we end and where
they begin and then how do we ensure
that it's our our influence that's
creating these decisions and it's not
some sort of external influence that's a
tough one I mean it's hard enough for us
to eat information responsibly now when
it's separate from us and and so that's
a those are new issues that future
generations are going to have to confirm
yeah and I guess it really begs the
question of like where is the
opportunity for something to go wrong
right because there's what data are you
collecting then how are you actually
categorizing the beta how are you
analyzing the data and then like what's
kind of the output of that entire
process and you know there's a lot of
people who frankly it scares the [ __ ]
out of them if Google and Amazon and
those companies are the ones doing that
stuff and kind of feeding them the
information or doing the analysis and
there's a lot of people who say wait a
minute
they're the smartest ones you know kind
of wanna on a holistic basis and so we'd
much rather have them do it rather than
you know Joe Blow in his basement who is
kind of untrusted unchecked and can kind
of do whatever he wants without any
transparency yeah that's the paradox
right I mean it's sort of like a comic
book character right be here long enough
and you become a villain right so we all
remember the nascent stages of the the
Google's and the Amazons and the
Facebook's and everything else where
they were considered heroic for helping
you know communities reach each other
right users you know far-flung
throughout the globe to be able to
communicate with one another to find any
sort of information and now you know we
have this new situation where they're
they're viewed as the villains because
they're so dominant successful and they
employ so many folks and they have undue
influence on political processes and the
like so you'll have new upstarts but
you'll also have the incumbents being
part of that
yeah for sure and I guess the the big
question most people have is just like
how did these technologies impact my
life and you know it's amazing that the
Alexa is the Google Holmes have all even
Siri have kind of infiltrated in a very
consumer friendly way people realize hey
look this is super helpful it does
provide me solutions but then I always
joke and say and the mystical Boston
Dynamics robot running through the
forest and they're like holy [ __ ] yeah
the robots are going to kill us all and
so it's really funny how I think
people's perspective is driven by the
use cases that they have and also what
they see information on line drives how
their interest all is with technology
and in in some ways
it's it's scattershot and you know for
every positive use of technology you'll
read a negative one and positive one and
negative one and you're going back and
forth like a yo-yo on this is good for
us or bad in some way is you know we
can't predict all the good that's going
to happen and it's going to be
surprising and we can't predict all the
bad that's going to happen and it will
surprise us as well certainly nobody you
know coming outside of New Year's Day
expect it you know everything to turn
out the way that it did in the first
half of of this year and and hopefully
we have pleasant surprises in front of
us just not unpleasant surprises too